Okay, so first things first, let's take a look at some lighting terminology
and what types of lights we have available in Unreal Engine 5.
The topics that we're going to cover in this
are going to be lighting definitions and types,
what the difference is between static lighting
versus dynamic lighting,
as well as what light types are available for us.
So, when we go to talk about lighting definitions
and certain terminologies that we'll be using,
and you'll hear me use this a lot as I go through this course,
direct lighting is the light that falls onto a surface
without any interference, so essentially from
the point that the light has been emitted
directly onto the object.
Then we have indirect lighting,
or bounce lighting.
So that's lighting that's been reflected by another surface
that's nearby, and bounces off that surface
onto the object that you're looking at,
carrying some of the color information
from the surface that it's bouncing off.
And then we have the shadows,
which happens essentially when
Unreal Engine takes a snapshot of a mesh
from a lighting's point of view and projects
that shadow onto the opposite side of the actor.
So, again, you'll hear me
use the terms direct lighting and direct lighting
quite a lot, so
just keep in mind what these both mean
and understand
how they differ.
When we talk about static versus dynamic lighting,
we have a few options inside of Unreal.
So Lumen
is the new Unreal Engine 5
fully dynamic global
illumination system. It renders the fuse
into reflection with infinite bounces
and indirect specular reflections
in large, detailed environments
from really, really small to large
setups.
Then we also have
baked or static lighting,
which is pre-computed lighting, similar to what
you'd see with
other rendering engines, such as V-Ray,
Corona, et cetera. It creates
high quality indirect lighting
and has no performance
cost, essentially, on
real-time, because everything's
pre-computed and stored in textures.
And then we have real-time
dynamic lighting, which is lighting that's
updated on each frame. It's fully dynamic
and can be moved around and modified at runtime.
It has no global illumination,
so there's only direct lighting, so no
indirect lighting
whatsoever, unlike Lumen.
But it's also very expensive to use
and it does affect real-time
performance.
Unreal Engine can use a hybrid
between both static and dynamic lighting,
so that's something to keep
in mind.
We have also ray-traced
lighting. This type of lighting
is real-time global illumination,
updated with all lights set to
movable. It's important to note that
some aspects of
ray tracing are taken into account with
Lumen, such as reflections and shadowing when needed.
But the important thing is
the difference between Lumen and ray-traced
lighting is that ray-trace
actually is hardware ray-tracing, which means
that you need a graphics card able to
support it, whereas Lumen doesn't necessarily
need that. It's software ray-traced,
so it does not actually need
a card, for example, like an RTX
Nvidia card, to
do its global
illumination calculations.
The light types that we're going to see, and I'm running through this
as I go here, but we'll be doing an exercise
later on so you can actually see each light
and how they all differ.
We have directional light, like a sun,
a point light, a spotlight,
rectangular light, a skylight,
and then a couple of extra light
setups here, which are called the HDRI Backdrop
and Sun and Sky, which essentially are a couple
of blueprints that are set up
for HDR lighting in the case of
HDRI Backdrops, and Sun and Sky
allows you to essentially
have a very accurate
sun positioning for a particular
latitude and longitude in a specific place.
Really nice
couple of blueprints that you can use there specifically
if you need them, or that sort of thing for your project.
Now, when it comes to the properties and settings of the
lights, we're going
to cover the light properties and the
mobility options for each light.
So, when it comes to the properties and settings
that we can change, for
point lights and spotlights,
we are looking at candelas,
lumens, or unitless setups
for the intensity.
Now, importantly, 100 watts on a light bulb
would be called 100 lumens.
However, the directional light, which is more like a
sun, is calculated in lux values.
In each one of the lights,
all these things are going to be common,
so we're going to have
the intensity,
indirect lighting intensity, so how much they
contribute to that indirect bounce lighting.
The attenuation, which is how
far from the emission
point of the light the light actually travels.
We can use
temperature if we want to, to change the color
without having to actually change the color
and use a temperature value.
Source radius and source angle.
Source angles you'll see
on the directional light and source radius you'll
see on every other type of light, which will allow you
to change the softness of the radius as well as
the size of the specular
reflection on the surfaces.
Whether to use
inverse squared falloff for lighting,
and this is something I recommend to just use
for everything since it's a more realistic
approach to set up lighting.
And then we also have IES profiles
if we want to actually change the
way that light is distributed based on
a particular
real-life profile.
When it comes to light mobility,
we have static, which essentially means
this light's going to be baked
indirect and direct lighting.
It's the cheapest to use once again as it gets
stored into textures and does not
have an impact in performance at real-time.
We've got stationary,
which is baked indirect lighting.
It's high quality
direct lighting
and shadows that are on the fly, essentially that's the
dynamic side of it.
But it has a limited use. You can only have a
maximum of four overlapping lights,
but it's the highest quality to
medium performance if you're using a static
lighting sort of set.
And then we have movable,
which is fully dynamic lights and shadows.
If you're using Lumen, you will get
indirect lighting out of this.
If you're not,
you will only get direct lighting,
as I mentioned earlier.
It has the highest performance cost.
And again, if you're not using Lumen, you won't
get indirect lighting, but again,
if you're using Lumen, you will.
That's really it. After this, we're just going to
get into actually taking a look at Lumen
as the premier
Unreal Engine 5 lighting system.
Let's go ahead and do that.